I believe that I know problem centers
around people trying to make money you
grew up in LA you grew up in Crenshaw
we always like this or did you work to
get to this point my personal opinion is
that you have to go out and earn your
position in federal prison I don't care
what your last name is you just like me
I look back in my rearview mirror I saw
him at Chico and Curtis out the car
you know handcuffed him to
black-and-white police cars blocking
intersection and I knew it was a setup
for me the only song cocaine because I
had no other Avenue can you imagine if
you have somebody who think that they're
dumb stupid they think they're
gangbanger but you thought all those
things about yourself absolutely there's
a direct parallel to not having
knowledge in going to prison what do you
see being the solution and I ask all the
kids in the schools who introduced you
to drugs
everybody said my brother my father my
auntie guess how many said a stranger
how many know
[Music]
so if you've seen the movie American
Gangster the story of Frank Lucas one of
the biggest african-american drug lords
in the East Coast the one on the west
coast was a man named freeway Rick Ross
in the 80s he sold nearly a billion
dollars of crack cocaine net profits 300
million dollars which the equivalent of
today would be twenty five billion
dollars gross 850 net and he did this at
a time where he didn't know how to read
and write with that being said today we
have Rick Ross really special coming up
now glad to be here it's good to have
you out here man Wow I mean I'm just
blown away man yeah I appreciate you for
coming out you know I got a lot of
directions I want to go obviously I've
seen your documentary and I want to talk
about a little bit about your story for
some that don't know but there's an also
an element of it that I want to talk
about that are you familiar with Sammy
the bull Gravano understand me so Sammy
the bull Gravano and I spent some time
together we were having a conversation
and one of the things we talked about is
that that that moment where a kid is
growing up he's innocent she's innocent
they don't know what's going on and then
all of a sudden they make a decision to
they turn in is that DNA is that
upbringing is that fatherless
environment is that is that culture is
that you know experiences in life I kind
of wanna hear what you think about
definitely definitely culture you know
we have to give the environment that we
brought up in a lot of credit because in
my personal humble opinion is that we
are accumulation of everything we saw
her and men around we take all that
information and we try to come up with
who we are and that's what
being yourself really is but in
actuality you are accumulation of
everything that you've come in contact
with and how you took that information
and deciphered it to be who it he
thought it should be so you do think
there's some of it that affects you I
guess the part I would be curious about
is how much of it is your wiring the way
you were born how much of it is
upbringing and how much of it is
experience is and what isn't like you
know a a rick ross in a complete
different environment what what
direction would you go who would be well
well we can tell that now because I'm
pretty much directing myself in the
directions that I want to go in and I'm
no longer allowing outside forces to to
direct Who I am and where I'm kind of
going I'm old enough now and wise enough
to make the decisions but you know with
us as human beings we're being bombarded
with people who are trying to control
our minds our bodies to perform the acts
that they want us to perform I'm curious
to hear about that
well marketing you know marketing is a
form of convincing people to do whatever
the marketer feel like they should be
doing so let me ask you before you going
into you know the drug route and you
being introduced to it if I was in high
school with you who was who was Rick
Ross I was a kid who thought that I was
gonna one day be playing in one more
turn of the US Open I had aspirations
have been a star tennis player had never
drunk a beer and never smoked a
cigarette had never had a joint ever not
at that time no totally a virgin you
know all the way around you know looking
for guidance looking for directions you
know not knowing what choices I should
be making and had some some some miss
Cummings as well you know had some
defects with what I thought was defects
but wasn't necessarily defects was a
position where I didn't understand the
principles and the rules of the game you
know it's like trying to play football
and you've been taught basketball rules
about life now your mother was in a
picture obviously and your father wasn't
in the picture at all no father wasn't
here there so who played the role of a
father in your life
Jeff of coaches you have a mentor well
I've had many many people come into my
life and play rows of mentor or fathers
and I've adopted people you know did I
pick the right people all the time no
now you went to Dorsey high school right
yes I used to sell memberships at Bally
Total Fitness and I would sell him at
Fox Hills Mall which he liked so small
you know a lot of my friends went to
Dorsey high yeah and we were talking
about Dexter sexy Dexter selling
memberships he played baseball my memory
is not really that that well from the
past I'm more of a forward thinking guy
like I could meet somebody last week and
if I run into them again I probably
won't remember who they are you know
that's one of the reasons that with me I
always try to treat everybody right
because if you treat them wrong you know
you run into him again and you don't
know how you treated them and then
they'd be like it's a funny story you
know I went out when I when I first got
the prison to Lompoc USP Lompoc and I'm
walking down the hallway and this guy
comes up to me and he's about six-two
six-three looked like he lives on the
way pal right he's all muscle he looked
like that statue ate almost that big -
right and and and I'm walking down the
hall when he walks right into me
he walks right into you intentionally
intention and he was like you know who I
am no no you are but I hope I didn't do
nothin to you and it was just so happy
that he was a young kid that
when he's about 14 15 years old and I
did right by and I was so glad that I
had yeah I was glad that I did right by
because uh I mean he looked like the
statue idea I mean the one thing what
she was you didn't create a lot of
enemies though people liked you you mean
your enemies like I hate it means I
don't want any enemies yes I want all
friends what would you what was your
strategy for doing that is it just you
know respect everybody was it a said you
gotta respect everybody I mean if you
don't respect everybody then you kind of
disrespect on yourself because in the
big picture we're all kind of joining
together you know it's like we're all
like sales on this planet that have to
function with each other you know nobody
lives on this planet without help from
somebody else you know and and I learned
that at an early age and and that was
one of my strong points you know just
treating everybody to weight it I want
it to be treated now so you're going up
you're doing what you're doing with
tennis at what point do you say I don't
know if I got a career with tennis and
you go a completely different direction
what happened well it was when when I
was in the 12th grade he was getting
closer in graduation time and all my
friends were filling out their college
papers and you know go to college too
and this coach is like man oh thank you
go making in college you know what I you
can't read you can't write you can't
read you can't write yeah I couldn't
read a couldn't mind at all at all zero
zero how did you get to eighth grade or
you know high school without being able
to read or I just kept passing me
through you know I would do just enough
to get by you know I would cheat off of
somebody's paper for a test a spelling
test or something like that and it would
always be just enough you know to get by
and the teachers liked me just enough
you notice they you know what I ain't no
holding back and when they didn't go
ahead and I think a part of their
thinking was that they didn't want to
hurt me you know they didn't want me to
be 16 years old in the first grade
[Laughter]
imagine that you 16 years old and you
sitting in the first grade and little
bitty chairs so so I felt that the
teachers had some some sympathy for me
you know it was a good thing no no no I
mean they could have had sympathy for me
and say you know what I'm gonna spend an
extra hour with him you know I'm gonna
spend the extra 30 minutes with him in
and I'm gonna keep him out at the class
and you know I'll show him what the
principles that he's missing because
really you know what with reading and
writing and with anything almost it's
almost principles you know learning the
fundamentals you know I didn't know the
fundamentals of reading I didn't know
that you had to sign your words out and
it was only when I was 28 years old I'm
a president and I'm looking at a life
sentence that my celly was able to
convince me that I could actually read
first I didn't believe me at 28 yeah I
didn't believe me but did he spend time
with you teaching it was it like yeah he
did we were sally's so you know I was in
you know we're in a maximum-security
facility you know where you locked down
most of the time so we had a lot of time
to spend together and you know he saw in
me that I had what it took to learn how
to read took about two weeks that's it
that's it so if the teachers early on
would have put that time into you will
learn how to learn in two weeks
absolutely how big of a difference would
that have made in your life oh my
goodness when Wow I fell in love we read
when I went out well I'm in prison so
you know how much to do you know you
can't chase women in prison you can't go
shoot basketball whenever you want to a
football or tennis so you kind of
confined to this area where reading
became my favorites worked well were
some of the best favorite books you read
and I heard you read 300 books which is
which is great but what were some of the
books my favorite books is richest man
in Babylon Wow great book oh my goodness
I read over 25 times richest man in
Babylon
you remember till today oh man come on
and they had that in prison I bought it
I bought the books so so will you bought
the books they send it to you yeah they
would send it to me what else the
richest man in Babylon is an incredible
book what else would you say Think and
Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill one of the 40
million copies sold no 100 so many you
know sort of 100 million copies 100
million maybe 60 million is underground
yeah yeah Oh what else what other books
did you read psycho cybernetics I didn't
read that okay I was part of that same
family yeah yeah as a man think great
book by James Allen after I read those
students are really gonna need to read
anything you know I don't know did you
get to read the article they did on me
in LA magazine this is not a web you're
not talking about webcasters Jesse cat
is the guy LA Times hired to go against
scary story remember they did a rebuttal
to Gary's story I mean I read stories so
if this is what I don't remember what I
know this is different when this came
after I got out of prison okay he didn't
I 90 not he wrote my my what he called
my obituaries they said he would send it
that the world was tired of me dreaming
and and they wasn't gonna be here for me
no more but in 2013 he had to rewrite
the story and inside of that story he
was talking about when I was in prison
how he thought I'd lost my mind because
I'm talking about how a movie getting
out and all the things I'm gonna be
doing on me be speaking at colleges and
this settling this yeah I'm telling me
what this is what I'm gonna be doing
when I get out how much of it is
inspired by the richest man in Babylon
I'm thinking college because what I had
did those books allowed me to go back
over my life and find out how I got in
prison so so you know going back to the
question I was asking is what can happen
to change the direction of a Rick Ross
at 10 at 12 and 11 in Babylon would have
changed that's what I'm saying so
somebody instead of reading that was
then this is now or mice of man I didn't
care why Jack and Jill was going up to
heal you
it wasn't going to get no money I didn't
want to know about Huntress ward none
but once once I started to see that
these books made me go back over my life
step-by-step that's how I wrote my book
that's on my first book because I went
back all my life and I started to do
step by step what are you doing here how
did you get here
and when I did that I said well you know
what Rick you work your way in prison
they just didn't put you in prison you
you earned it
you only be here like like I tell kids
all the time when you go to when I go to
the schools and speak I say look you can
go to the prison right now go to the
gate ring the bell
knock on the gate then I'll come out and
ask you what you want and you ask them
can you go in and they're gonna say no
you can't come in here you have to go
out and earn your position in federal
prison they don't just take anybody you
know they like the army where you just
go sign up no you got to go out and earn
your position so I went out and I earned
that life sentence that I got you know
and when I figured out that I could earn
it then I figured out that I could diss
on it that's what I did I started to
work just as diligently in getting out
of prison as I did to get in and this
leads you to start studying law start
studying in law politics you know I
started studying politic why politics
well in in in federal prison
if say for instance all the judges
wouldn't would have denied all my
Appeals then I could have played
politics to still get out in my and Mike
am I thinking and you know I was
thinking crazy to like I was going to
become so smart that the jails couldn't
hold me that the people from the United
States was gonna cry out so loud for my
freedom that the jails wasn't gonna be
able to hold me
whoever the president was Congress
thought they all would have been like
let him out of there we need him on the
streets you know we need more of him and
that was my plan the plan was get so
smart that they need you on the streets
rather than in prison
exactly Wow now if we go back but how
did you get into the drug world how did
that happen well you know I just found
out that I wasn't gonna be going to
college I didn't have any sponsors for
tennis I didn't know what I was gonna do
with my life you know I saw this movie
one time called super fly where this guy
had started selling cocaine and he got
rich and he beat the police and
everybody and I was like oh and it's
kinda just went over my head you know
nothing you know I didn't know about the
subconscious mind at that time you know
I didn't know that you can't be giving
scenes to the subconscious mind like
that you know because there's inner work
and then act on it and then just one day
I was just sitting on my porch and I'm
contemplating like wow you got a
miserable life where you you don't have
gas money you have no food if your mom
has stopped feeding you you're done and
my friend called me and he was like man
I got something new and I was like he
was like come by and I went by and he
put it on the table some white powder
and looking stuff and and I was like
what's dad he said that's cocaine I said
oh yeah what you doing with that he was
like I said it music CDs go change yes I
got him and I was like wow
is it really like that and he was like
oh man this is a new thing and that's
how I got started how old were you at
the time m1919 you know how quickly
after that did you start selling well I
started that day that day he gave me he
gave me $50 worth to go and see what I
could do with it and I started going
around asking everybody really I didn't
know I was marketing you know I'm
accident hey you know about cocaine and
is this really cocaine and finally uh
you know most people didn't know what it
was and then finally I found somebody
who did Martin that was my first my
first getting beat I got beat out of
that cocaine and but that was my first
sale as well
first seller for speeding yeah and so
you go back and what happens there
at what point you start scaling it well
after he used all that cocaine that I
had and didn't give me any money but
later on that day he came back with
somebody else to spend a hundred dollars
you know some of my business started it
was just kept going after that but at
what point where you're like starting to
make real money wouldn't you start
making real money that's 19 well it took
it took about took about seven or eight
months
you know before I started to do maybe
like three or four hundred hours every
day you know it didn't it didn't start
off like a lot of people like now you
know it's a little different now than it
was when I first started and even we
didn't have cocaine what they call
cocaine tracks you know like now they
have places that you can go and they
already have people who were looking for
cocaine at those areas so you could go
there and you might make you know like
we used to have a spot that would do
fifty thousand dollars in one day you
know you could go out on the street just
stand out on the street and have cocaine
and you might make fifty thousand if you
can beat everybody out on the block
you know it's other people out competing
for that same money but if you were good
then you could collect all that money or
most of it in and that's how I started
out you know but I had to build that
Street up myself
I built a Street up and then other guys
came the street that I built up probably
Sidhu 100
not as a day just them one okay day yeah
one Street now
you don't seem threatening you're not a
big guy you're a small guy why are
people not bullying you out of street
though you know why are they letting you
do it why aren't people saying hey get
out of here you know or beating you up
well well you have to it mean you have
to have tact you know it's tactful you
have to have being tactful you know and
what I always do is I share with other
people you know I don't take the money
myself and just use it for me you know I
like to share and once you share with
with other people even someone someone
was stupid enough though still you know
to take a knife and stab the goose to
slander golden eggs you know but
majority other people to have a tendency
at least a lot of goose to live you know
oh you just run around and I get a egg
every now and then you know and that's
pretty much the way that that they
allowed me to function and what you're
is this you're saying seven months later
you're 19 20 years old what you're
you're looking at 80 this is 80 80 so
scaling to you having hundreds of people
working for you how long did it take to
get to that point was their new
relationship was there somebody that
came in well most of my guys started to
get involved you know like all my
friends it's like when you start to find
I mean you know like hitting a lottery
you know somebody hit the lottery didn't
haul down family members want to be
around when I talk to them and it's the
same thing in the drug business you know
once people see you being successful
they they want a part of it some kind of
way you know they usually want a handout
but someone might actually do a little
work to get that then handout how are
you recruiting people I was looking for
people in the same position that I was
in
you know people that had all the skills
all the talents but didn't know what to
do with it and conversation what's it
sound like you're talking to me what do
you tell I say fence out I could walk in
the gym you know going to play
basketball and it might be one of the
what we call young homies who would be
at the gym and I'm gonna use one of the
ones who testified against me and he
said he was sitting in the gym and when
I tell his story it seems almost similar
to mine you know when I was sitting on
the porch and didn't know what I
was gonna do what he was sitting on on
the stage at the gym and he didn't know
what he was gonna do and I was like man
what you doing with yourself you know
you didn't make it in baseball and this
kid played baseball and I was like so
what you're gonna do now he was like no
no I want you to go with me
you know we don't we do pretty good for
ourselves you know we feeding our
families we got houses we got cars try
this route you know he got off the stage
and he went with me how quickly did he
start selling oh the same day don't take
long did I mean you know selling jokes
is easy a nine-year-old kid can really
do it you know if they if they could
defend themselves from from the bullies
like you say it it's it's simple and in
some ways I mean it's it's it's it's
genius but it's also a simple trade if
you know what what you're doing I mean
really anything though is once you know
this amazing what you're seeing is how
subconscious mind you're like I allowed
that superfly message to get into my
head for me to think about that so but
at what what point I guess the part I'm
trying to get to is was there a
relationship you got where all of a
sudden you went from making three five
hundred dollars a day to make him three
hundred thousand dollars a day well
first I was getting you know I was
getting my drugs from my friend who went
who went to college who introduced me to
it and then I started dealing with a
teacher mr. Fisher who had a connection
that I didn't know about when he turned
me on the connection I went from I think
we were buying like sevens you know
quarter quarter ounces and uh when we
started doing it dealing with him and
his and his his friends our quality got
better and our prices got cheaper so it
started to escalate from there to where
now we're doing thousand dollars a day
you know and it just escalated from
there to five thousand dollars a day ten
thousand dollars a day and he got to the
point to where the first one that we
were dealing with he got he got
paralyzed his wife shot him in the back
he got paralyzed why did his wife shoot
him in the back it was just a fight you
know she can probably you know okay I
never found out the reason but when he
got paralyzed his brother-in-law took
over his business his brother-in-law
wasn't really he never really had an
appetite for it you know he wasn't
really like a business guy so what he
did is he sold me to the connect he sold
you to the connect yeah he sold me to
connect any so to connect to me how did
that kind at a conversation an
introduction he came to me one day and
he was like he spoke broken English till
he was from Nicaragua and he was like
man I want out of this business I don't
like this business somebody had got
busted one of his people had got busted
and he was he was scared today my tail
so he was like man I don't like this
business I want to be out but I want to
introduce you to the connection and I
was totally for that then you know price
came up how much and he wanted 200 grand
but I was able to talk him down to 60
grand why I gave him 60 just for the
connect just introducing me to the
connect so he give me the 60 you get
connected then what happens we start
booming how quickly well I was already
I was already I mean I was already
getting rich yeah at that time you know
I probably had a few hundred thousand
dollars at that time how are you at that
time well you knew early 20s 21 22 to 23
maybe okay
got it still young but yeah you know up
in age you know the day we met men
dinero first met I think we did like 50
kilos that day day one yeah day one good
we already kind of knew each other you
know like it's like you know somebody
but you don't you know that man I sure
wish I could talk to him you know but we
had never out of respect you know you
can't jump over you'll you'll connect
you know then it has to be done properly
so
I'd already know who he was so meeting
him was just like okay this is what I've
been waiting on so he dropped the price
a couple of thousand dollars as soon as
we met you know a couple thousand per
kilo and I mean you talk about a couple
without a couple thousand dollars per
kilo is a lot you know I'm saying you do
50 keys that's 100 grand
extra extra not what you've been making
but this is the hundred grand extra so
you start making that kind of money
every single day every single day and
and then you know now some days we're
doing 200 kilos you know my day a day
yeah each kilo you're making how much
profits 2000 2500 yeah I mean it's quite
an who comes you know the guys who are
buying like 20 20 kilos at a time you
probably making like 2,000 off for them
2500 who are your customers but most
dealers your customers dealers Redeemers
I kind of like created my dealers to you
know I would I had come up with a
formula where I would go into the
community and by me knowing I grew up
there so I knew all the people all the
players you know I knew him so I knew
who would be basically what they call
the influencers now you know the guys
who was telling people what to do how to
do it and they ran their neighborhood
shot-callers as we used to call them why
why did the shot-callers allow you to
keep the influencer Blandon and not go
through you to get direct to the connect
well they didn't know who he was
I wouldn't let him meet planned on so I
could buy my own drug so they never had
to to to see blando you know when they
when Brandon would come I had two money
buy all the drugs and then I could take
the drugs in southern Italy settlement
when they asked him you're like hey you
know Rick who's the guy who was the guy
nobody was asking literally nobody was
asking why weren't they asking they were
doing better than they'd ever thought
about doing before in their life but
greed gets some people to want to go
through you and you know get even a
bigger contract what I do I mean what
wind up happening is is eventually you
know when these guys become millionaires
and then other dealers come into the
city and and that's why the price went
down so low you know before I went to
prison
first kilo I bought I think I paid like
48 thousand for it the first whole kilo
vote but now when I was buying ounces I
was paying thirty three hundred foot one
ounce so you talked about if you do 33
times 36 you're talking about paying
something like a hundred and something
per kilo and when I first started by my
first kilo I paying 48 so the price was
substantially sure yeah no way yeah at
that time but before I quit the last
Kingdom I bought was like 9500 get out
of here yeah from a hundred yeah so that
shows you how how much the price came
down and this is going to the height of
the war on drugs so even though the
Reagan era yeah the war on drugs was
going full steam ahead the price of the
cocaine was going down which was making
it more accessible to more people
how are you staying low-key at this time
I just dressed the way I always dress
you know I didn't need any jury I came
to a point in my life to where I didn't
need to show anybody what I was doing
you know who I was or how how I wanted
to be perceived so you take me the way I
am or or leave it did you ever watch
them working gangster I did it was so
when you watch it what you think about
it uh they were pretty close and you
know it wasn't bad on mine
I enjoy some of the other guys on on
there that I watched uh and I learned
lessons from them as well I mean I mean
you know it's it's like a lesson you
know you can you can take lessons from
it but on my particular memory matter of
fact you know I'm working with Reginald
Hudlin right now the guy who did
agreement American Gangster series for
BT we're working together right now in
my movie when you're over yeah so I felt
pretty good about the job that he did he
was pretty fair you know he didn't he
didn't slam me you know the way he could
have I guess now you and Frank have done
events together yeah we did when he was
alive yeah we did
how was that when you're suffering like
what's the conversations like there was
no conversation we had a little
conversation man Frankel common
different people you know Frank was
prettier than I was I think you know he
he treated people a little different
than and I treat people I didn't really
like the way he talked to people is if
he put herself on a pedestal and I don't
believe that any of us should be on a
pedestal I don't care how much money you
got
I don't care what your last name is you
know what movie you played in you just
like me you know you got to go to the
bathroom and take a piss just like I do
how did you stay humble you know that I
mean you got 300 million dollars of net
profits in the 80s what's the most cash
you ever had to yourself okay and like
3.2 million cash counted I still have
money on the street that's the most cash
I had 3.2 million yeah got it
so then you got cash on the street
that's doing its work you're making your
money you're living large people at that
time sometimes are tempted to do crazy
things what was your vice I didn't want
to go to prison you know and I knew that
if I would do something stupid you know
like maybe somebody old like cope you
owe me like one guy owed me like 360,000
and my guys want to go in drag him out
the house and demolish him right and I'm
like okay okay let's talk about it first
cuz you got a good point
now I take your point in consideration
which I said we do that and then we
killed him in homicide gonna come in and
they're gonna be investigating they're
gonna try to figure out who did it
maybe they won't find out it was us
maybe they will maybe they just
suspicious that it was us and they
coming to arrest us how much is that
gonna cost
how much bill don't cause Oh party about
50,000 each one of us and then
and what Allen Finster going cause to
fight the case he popping almost $80,000
I said okay so it's six of us in here
that's fifty each
you know I'm saying so that's three
hundred thousand-plus
Allen's 80 just for one and then we got
to get everybody else lawyers and we
ain't gonna get that money back so were
you a math guy we if you were now if you
couldn't read or write I know math it's
very obvious I mean you're just doing
math right in front of me talking to me
yeah I love math math I think math and
math and science is really all we need
you know if you can do math and science
what do you say that well you know the
art of science is is breaking things
down to figure out their their origins
or what it's going to do you know in the
future you know like when you plant a
seed in the ground you you you are
looking forward to perform a certain
function in the future and that's pretty
much what what life is about you know
the thing that I think that I do well is
I can take what's going on today and see
what's going on what's gonna happen
tomorrow you can take what's going on
today and see what's gonna happen
tomorrow yeah how can predict what's
gonna happen tomorrow like I can go to a
stream and I can look at the street and
I can pretty much predict what type of
building should be there what
neighborhoods is gonna be there
you know I don't know where I get it
from but I can just do it and I do the
same thing with people you know I can
look at a person and I can kind of tell
like just what you should be doing I'm
telling you you might not listen to me
but that's that's your call interesting
interesting so you're you're vice at the
time when you're coming up it's it's
what it's purely woman because you're
not using drugs yourself no did you ever
try crack cocaine any of that or I tried
crack a couple times I think I might
have used for about a week straight you
know when I when I got to an ounce right
I've got times I think I'm rich I don't
say that time is work about nine
thousand broke down you know to the lab
to the last term you know you sell every
every 20 you make about nine thousand so
I when I got my first ounce I was like
yeah I'm here I'm there yeah I mean it
and I'm thinking I'm rich right
and so my cousins who I didn't really
understand addiction at that time you
didn't understand addiction uh no I
didn't they were already using and it
was like well man you're older than you
yeah we all run the same age maybe you
you know wanted to uh someone were
younger they convinced me to try it man
you've been doing all the sacrificing
you got all that you know I got like a
little pile blue handful of doors you
got all that dope now you know what
trying to see what everybody else like
cuz it doesn't get curious that brings
me to another one of my points I believe
that I don't cry on centers around
people trying to make money it doesn't
center around people trying to be drug
addicts most people who use drugs right
now don't start off to be drug addicts
they start off trying to be hustlers and
they fall victim to their own product so
when we sit in here they convinced me
into trying and I tried it looking for
me though I got sick and bumming been a
act at the league I was like man you
know you wouldn't posed to be doing that
and all of the older guys who who I was
selling to had already told me if you
don't use you gonna get rich so you
don't use your go to your engines
so when I finished and I come up out of
this this this coma that on me in this
drug hi coma that I mean I might had
$300 you know I was like no Rick this is
not what you got into this for you're
never using again I told myself that
you're never gonna use again and I just
never did interesting I started smoking
weed though they don't later on yeah how
old party six months later six months
later permanently regularly yeah every
day so we there's a regular thing for
you not now no I mean it wasn't in you
go now I do edibles now you do a
dependence on musiah it's it's what's
the biggest difference for you edibles
versus smoking it cheaper cheap like you
need the edibles you say how I can buy
like a bag of edibles a barback edibles
like 15 bucks and I last me for a week
a bag of edibles yeah like I might take
one one they got these little while
Chuy's and I'm gonna do my own choice to
for vegans they got big and chewy
Thursday so I'll give I'll get a bag of
those and I'll take one every day or you
know if I want to go to some days I
don't do it I'll do it at night when I
go to go to bed and it just puts me in
this space where it allows my mind it
kind of like drift down a little bit
because one of the things about me is my
mind it's constantly going you know it
never stops it never it never rest it's
just like all the time coming up with
this idea that idea this formula you
know and and sometimes I like to like
shut it down you know like just relax it
and try to calm me down interesting and
it helps so so you're on fire you're
doing great things now are you guys
using forcep that time with you guys
like into the whole killing thing is
that happening or not we must let you
work who knows what know for know but
now you guys got guns because blendin's
oh no no no we got we got artillery but
it's self-defense
purely self-defense yeah well you figure
you know you run around la you're doing
you know two months three million out of
cocaine deals every day every day I'm
doing it so every day we're carrying
duffle bags a money you know I'm talking
about like those big army bags how is it
that your your net profits in the 80s
was 300 million but the max you ever had
it was 3.2 million 3.2 million is not a
lot of money are you spending a lot of I
got a lot of people that that that is
eaten off the plate too you know it's
not just me eating I probably my average
profit every day was about 200-300
thousand per day per day so how do you
have how do you have only 3.2 million
my cars do your property you buy it I
got cars - and that car's not not
personal cars
you know I got card because when you're
in the drug business you you want to
switch cards I probably at that time I
probably have about 25 30 cars but
without your name no not in my name and
they not fancy cars they just switch
cars you know like a car you you you
drive because you know anybody know what
you drive your old strategy at the time
yeah Australia well it wasn't it wasn't
a time for play guess who's all work I
was building motels you know at a motel
and I think I build on motels like 22
years old when I build my first Motel
because my mom kicked me out the house
she found out I was selling drugs so she
kicked me out so now I'm living in
motels and I was like wow these motels
$45 a night and I can't get a room you
know I'm sitting outside the hotel room
and they don't have no rooms and you
know I got a hundred thousand dollars in
my pocket but I can't get Oh tell them
and I was like everyone can't be that
expensive to bill you know won't you
build one and I started I build a motel
and before I got arrested I was in the
process of building like three more and
that's really watch me my money you know
buying houses you know I would be
driving down the street and I see a
house that was abandoned and boarded up
and I'll be like oh I'm over I had to
fix it up this house should look like
this at the max how many properties did
you want max max by about thirty thirty
properties max yeah if I would have had
all my properties right now that I had I
probably be worth about 150 200 million
dollars this one was a commercial
property you're not talking my regular
like homes oh no I didn't buy a home for
myself okay I didn't want home yet you
so you're living out of what you're
living out of a part menteur you're
living in apartments houses one of my
places you know I would have my
girlfriends that houses you know about
Timoney houses but it wasn't the kind of
house dad that I saw myself living in
forever you know it was like you know a
nice neighborhood you know just a nice
house you know I'm saying but they were
young - you know 22 years old 21 years
old they they got a house and a mom I
didn't have a house you know so they
felt good about themselves and at this
point you're running in 42 cities is
that the right number is at about 42
cities not me personally I probably I
probably personally did
six or seven maybe six or seven yeah how
come you don't want to scale did you
have any desire of scaling going into a
different stage going to Nevada going
away Mexico Arizona it's hard to do it
you know by yourself you know it's crazy
and you know I don't don't really want
to you know be be dumping on my friends
but I was almost like I was doing
everything myself you know when when
when I was sitting in prison and I was
like you know your guys ain't send you
no money
your guys ain't looking out for you and
I was a little mad at him you know like
I come in here you know didn't say
nothing about nobody kept my mouth shut
nobody got arrested but uh nobody really
like looked out for me you know the only
person really came to see me was my mom
my girlfriends came and you know the
first couple months you know but they
were out fast so then now you find
yourself you in prison by yourself you
know nobody and you start to like
analyze your company you know the people
that you you kept the company lit and
you like why aren't they doing more for
me you know why aren't they trying to
help me accomplish my missions you know
and as I analyze them I started to
seeing defaults you know things that
they didn't have and it was almost like
I was kind of like propping them up you
know matter of fact I had a speech with
him a couple of weeks ago in and I was
telling them it's like that sometimes I
feel like I'm working with the Bad News
Bears you know the guys who can't came
they came back they came around it's
like wow man when you do is gonna pick
your axe up and uh it's hard to find
good people I mean you know I didn't
who's friends with you till today other
guys all my friends all my other guys
you ran with all of them
how can call anyone I'm right now if I
need whatever they do whatever for so
the same guys didn't show up are still
friends till today with you yeah and and
and when I say they didn't show up it's
not it's not necessarily a bad thing
that they didn't show up they just
didn't know
they just didn't know that they should
be showing up they didn't know like the
other day I was talking to him to it to
my friends and my families and I was
telling them like I work right now so
that my friends need my help I want to
be in a position to where I can help
them they would help me if they could
but they can't because they're not
putting themselves in a position to be
able to if they're making these
sentences so you don't put any of it on
them
you're not even putting in any of it on
them you don't have any you have zero
expectations of human beings in the
world it's not a first statement yeah
pretty pretty fascinating and because of
then you relax you're free you're happy
nobody can disappoint you
no they can't no one can disappoint you
know well you always liked this or did
you work to get to this point I don't
know I don't know if those books kind of
you know we know those books kind of
like put me in a space that uh you know
we supposed to pursue knowledge as human
beings and in those books allow me to to
really like break down everything you
know it's almost like this book right
here you know this book right here this
this this this book is it's gonna be
amazing
this book is about my first six months
out of prison and the guy who wrote it
with me Koli he he started writing me
when I was in prison when I was here in
Texarkana prison and he was like man I
want to put you on a cover of my
magazine I said okay I like that idea so
I got out he flew me to New York we did
the interview
so he was like man I want to be around
you more I also told him about those
three books I was like man how you
entrepreneurial you ain't where at these
three books you ain't no real
entrepreneur you fake in the game so he
read the books so when he came out to to
hang out with me cuz I really had no
friends I mean my old friends was there
but you know they're homeless and how
old you got the start I got out when I
was 49 49 yeah just a September 29th yep
so so we riding around and and I look at
him he keeps shorting down in this it's
notebook and I was like man what are you
doing every time we come out of me and
you always try now that in the book he's
like oh I was just documenting the
meeting and I was like Koli you've been
documenting every single day everything
that I've been doing he's like yeah man
I like the way you work those principles
I said coldly that's a book I said
everybody gonna want to know how I was
using these principles in how I took the
stuff that I got out of richest man in
Babylon and thinking Grow Rich and as a
man think along with my past experiences
and Kemah with another strategy for
myself I said man that's a book and
that's how this book came about you're
safe riding with Rick Kemetic he
documented it for six months
so did you ever have a moment where you
kind of sitting out there saying man I
don't know how much good we're doing I
may be making my friends money there's a
partner in documentary where one of your
friends talks about when the baby was
born and a doctor asks the jury use
crack cocaine he says no then he asked
the wife you know and he says I'm
holding my baby and she's got a scar
every time I see this car to remind her
of me says that's the day when I decided
to stop doing any selling anything
right did you ever have an experience
like that cuz he tells a story about a
ten-year-old comes to his door because
he wants some some crack cocaine and he
was sold to drugs by 13 year old than a
16 year old did you ever have a guy like
you that's very calculating your thinker
your you don't like to use violence
because of your mom killing your uncle
George when you were you
right in front of what a gun because you
have seen hit her one time with a stick
over and she lost the right now you got
so what are you in this point at every
sin they're saying dude I may be making
a lot of money but I'm hurting
a lot of people did you ever go out it
took a while before because in the
beginning it was all about everybody
making money and there were no
crackheads
if you can just vision can you vision
everybody that smoking crack got enough
money to pay for it at first one of the
worst things about it is that you can't
get enough
you're not gonna OD but you're not gonna
get enough I mean if you sit here and
you got 4,000 you're not gonna be enough
for you you're gonna keep going keep
going into the hole 4,000 it's gone it's
it's just it's like that mentality of
people who use crack they want to burn
up all their money when I first started
it was really crazy you know you would
hear people saying yeah I blew a boom
500 last night and I blew $500 so the
main thing was in the beginning was they
weren't sleeping on the street they were
prostituting when did that happen though
I mean I took a couple of years it did a
couple years later though
like did you have I guess what I'm
trying to find out from you is from from
that perspective is are you purely a
logical guy where you know you your coal
to the point where I don't see any of
this stuff so no no I'm sure that's not
you I saw I started to meet your kids
I started to see it but it took a while
to see it you know you just know what is
the first time what was the first time
we're like oh we're actually hurting
people well the first time that I really
let me say let me say this here I
started to feel like a hypocrite it's
when I noticed that I started to change
my mindset because at first I used to
give it to my girlfriend used to give it
to my brothers to get high you know I
did nothing
yeah get out you can't smoke all the
cocaine I got so here go go go get high
but it came to a point to where I no
longer would give them cocaine and then
I didn't want them getting high anymore
so at that point that I knew it was
addictive once I knew that I didn't want
my family getting high then I started to
understand what I was doing to other
people's families you know I didn't want
my girl my brothers my sisters my mom
but my auntie's getting high and I
didn't feel that it was right for me to
be selling cocaine to other people's
family members did you stop at that time
was it kind of like not too much later
you know you don't you know just kick
the habit you don't go cold turkey most
people don't I'm not able to go cold
turkey just immediately how much of it
to get away from and you think it's
knowing that you can outsmart anybody is
it kind of like to the point where I
think I'm invincible I think I got smart
anybody
I think I'm strategically better smarter
than these guys was it yeah I felt like
that too you know I didn't feel that the
police could catch me I thought that I
could stay ahead of the police I could
stay ahead of the streets you know the
guys who do the robbing and yeah you
felt like that you know but I quit I
could about a year before I went to
prison you know this is when he went to
Ohio so yep Cincinnati but after after I
came back from why cuz I started back
Sunday I started back selling when I was
in Ohio because we back you try to try
no you were trying to buy the motels and
I think he was trying to do some of the
Real Estate's yeah I was already doing
that though when I was selling the drugs
the drugs financed the real estate but
when I went to Cincinnati I wanted to
just chill out and then I started back
selling drugs so that was part of me
trying to pull away you know how you
you're trying to pull away with you you
just don't do it
it took Cincinnati getting in trouble in
Cincinnati one of my guys got caught at
the bus station you know
I did everything I could for him and he
still got 20 years so that was when I
was like you know what this is the time
today the ones that rat you out for his
rat address were Cincinnati or no like
how do they find out about who's behind
this entire he didn't rat me out him the
one who got caught and got the 20 he
didn't but the guy who was on the stage
that I was telling you about
earlier he did when I quit Cincinnati
and went back what they did is they went
and started working all on my
connections you know I had houses down
here I had cars cuz when I left I just
left my houses and cars and everything I
didn't take no furniture out you know I
just just left the place and what they
did is they went back and they started
using all of my all my resources and all
my connections and everything so one of
them started messing with a DEA agent
that eventually busted him no connection
to Blandon
no no so this time you're blending are
still good your business regularly yeah
he is financing what he's doing for the
freedom fighters the whole CIA
conspiracy yeah you know wouldn't it
kind of go he's doing what he's doing
he's being allowed to do what he's doing
what what happens for you to get caught
and go to prison first time they told
him they got busted down in Cincinnati
you know when they got busted they threw
me in in an operation I mean it was
pretty easy you know I mean it's pretty
easy for what how to Fayed's work you
know the feds can work off of almost
what they call circumstantial evidence
the way they do it is they draw they
draw a picture and they will explain to
the jury that this picture is not going
to be totally complete you know wasn't
captured on film it was just a picture
that was drawn and in this picture
there's gonna be elements it's not gonna
be totally complete but it's gonna be
enough of a picture to where you can
emphasize and as a jury member you
allowed to emphasize so what they did is
they came up with evidence first they
prove that that I was in Cincinnati
you know they had like some rental
agreements
my fingerprints on it also had a fake ID
from Cincinnati they had that then all
the guys that had got arrested stayed in
my general area you know showing that we
were friends that we were connected then
they would show the jury that and you
can believe that this guy really knows
where and if you believe what he's gonna
say about Rick it's true then you can
convict wick of what he said Rick did
and they were talking about oh I was
with Rick one Danny so Tinky's and he
sold it to this guy Ronnie being he sold
five to this guy Jerry and you know and
so forth for so long and he went to New
York one time I went with him and we
picked up we stayed at this hotel or one
night and we did this deal and and
that's how they build a case so how much
times you do do it the first time I did
it uh five years in like four months
five or four months yeah when you get
out do you have any cash still left no I
really got out I was broke I think law I
think I had a couple pieces of property
there if I still had that theater did I
was trying to be ill what else and I
thought it was that in which the Los
Angeles watch part in Crenshaw
or right on for crunch oh yeah by the
mole no not by the Crenshaw it was right
down the street from the question okay
got it
crunch Sean Adams Adams going on the
other side not by the mall no right by
right behind freeway
why by the team you know the first
speech I ever get was at the Sizzlers by
Crenshaw mall I don't know if you
remember his sister's my crush them all
right by the theater because there's the
theater then magic if you the theater
right on first message I gave yes 21
years old God I got out of military it
was a Sizzlers I was nervous as hell I
got up and spoke and you guys me to give
a message oh you know what Susan you
should be on over heal visually I can
tell you exactly where it's at and where
I parked the car yeah I'm trying to
pitch a little bit so be she eclipses
I'm trying to think of where sinners it
had to be behind them all right right it
was behind them all
like it wasn't at all by it was
completely behind them all I know you
talked this was a 99 no we're talking
about 20 years ago I just went to
present 99
oh no 99 no no I mean I know you do five
years a few months you get out when you
get out now what happens this is when
I'm gonna live a clean life I'm not
gonna do nothing and ain't you back yeah
I already came up with a few strategies
of what I could do my plan wasn't going
to music business I still had that
theater I felt that this theater would
be like the Apollo because you know when
I when I started to analyze my life I
looked at it I could have been a king of
hip-hop you king of hip-hop you know I
could have been including me brother
well I had I had the opportunities to to
do deals with some of the biggest people
ever in here bout 80s and 80s you kind
of like what sugar did yeah but before
shield okay so like maybe even bigger
than [ __ ] this is before yeah yeah I
have money before Russell had money you
know I remember when Russell was running
around La with with LL Cool J and Run
DMC and he had no money and he was
looking for money you know and I could
have went to him and gave him money
which one which one of the hip-hop guys
in LA knew you know I know Warren G was
you know maybe well I knew right I knew
him before before one G this is a before
one this is like DJ Pooh dr. Dre when
when they were barely barely be known at
that time the hot the hot rappers was
like King tea-masters payee time yes we
talked about you know $300 in to $900
yeah yeah so so I was right there when
those guys were first learning how to
work the drum machines and and then I
also had the other hand where I knew the
guys were distributing music you know I
knew oldest me if I knew dick Griffey I
met Barry Gordy one time so it would
have been very easy for me once you do
it once you get into it well I did you
know I gave over to Smith a 600,000 to
do Anita Baker's first album but I still
had my foot inside the dope game and I
wasn't really
like putting my energy into the music I
didn't really understand that where
music was going at that time you know I
couldn't see that that that hip-hop was
going to blow up and and I'm also
listening to - Otis and dick and these
guys who were telling me that hip-hop
was a fad that it wasn't or a bug was a
fad they told me hip-hop was a fan
literally literally yeah that's it they
are the reason that I'm not the king of
hip-hop unbelievable that I've listened
an EM because they have platinum and go
albums you know I think Otis had found
Rick James and Bobby Womack and Johnny
Taylor and dick Griffey you know he
found babyface and midnight star
midnight star midnight through me like
Reggie Calloway yeah yeah Jay King some
of these names yeah Jay King Club
Nouveau no Jay I got Genoa in my phone I
saw Jay an insurance policy 15 years ago
is there j1j what that says to me he
says hey as a Jay what do you want to do
he says you want to sell some policies
as I do he took me Jay took me to well
if he's listening to this he's gonna
crack up we went to Beverly Hills Hilton
Hotel we sat down LL Cool J cane sugar
was there I said Jay I can't sell a
policy to Suge Knight
no one's gonna social matter Bob when he
first got started
how was he was he a tough guy was a
rugged or no was he I believe he took a
lot of hereos traits and a lot of hereos
ideas of how to to really do the
business me an area was Sally's when we
were in prison and I was there when he
told David Kenner it was me him and
David Kenner sit in an attorney room and
he was like I'm gonna teach you how to
make more money than you ever would have
made doing law and I was sitting right
there with him
interesting so so so now you're out okay
five years few months you're out you're
getting back into it pretty quickly or
are you kind of taking a break from it
from what the drug business the drug
this
not doing no job at all you know and
then how does blending come in how does
that well he started calling me the same
day I got home I guess you know da party
told him okay we let him out today get
started so when I'm doing now I'm
running around and my goal now is cuz
I've saw death row
I saw a Harry Uhl and should be a death
row so I'm working on the music industry
I'm gonna do the same thing while you're
creating your youth center because I
know you will create rice I was doing a
new center and that was a whole new
strategy to that then I put together the
youth center was going to be it could be
a youth center / concert hall where all
the rappers might the ADA would've held
like 4,000 people 4,000 people yeah it
had a stage big enough to put like four
cars on it four thousand people's forty
thousand square foot building that's a
good size yeah I paid a million when I
paper that million - with what money
though you said you came out you don't
have money no I bought it before I went
to prison ha got it got it so that's
wonderful and the property's just -
laughs yeah I still have and I paid I've
been paying for that six thousand
dollars a month while I was in prison
- keep it because I put I put nine
hundred thousand down on it and I sold
300,000 and the way that the thing I
rolled up because my girl finished the
deal I didn't finish the deal I I
started buying it and I got arrested and
in between me buying and in him and
finishing the deal so she allowed them
to write the paperwork up for six
thousand dollars a month which was too
much I should've been paying anyway so
the whole time I was in prison I was
paying $6,000 a month on Epona building
so when I got out my intention was to
create like a West Coast Apollo for
rappers and it was on Crenshaw and Adams
so what I saw is this grand place where
every rapper in the country would be
saying man I want to go to Rick's place
well your is this now 94 94 yeah so did
you have any run-ins with Tupac I never
met pop-pop III didn't meet Park because
I was messing with right neon Joe Cooney
I knew I knew and Joe Cooney and when I
got out Park and Cooley Park and Joe had
just had words
and so before I met pot Joe was telling
me that that their hands just dissed him
or something you know Park this thing
that won the show so I didn't have no no
no intentions I'm going to meet pop you
know it was like have we meet we meet
but I'm not pursuing a meeting with Paco
he knows he knows of you at the time
obviously I'm pretty sure he did I'm
pretty sure he did so you're trying to
do this part lemon calls you he keeps
following up with you then what happens
well he's trying to get me to do a drug
deal
George Chico well this was before before
Chico came into picture Chico came into
picture later he had been trying to get
me before Chico even came into picture
Chico came into picture because one of
my old friends Chris who had had been
one of my main guys when I sold cocaine
had came by and he was like yeah man uh
my young boy he's like my young boy Rick
you probably remember him he was young
when you left the streets you know he's
doing good now he got studio equipment
and blah blah blah Chris had just got
out of jail to from Texas he was I don't
bail and he was saying you need to hook
up with him cuz he's doing the music
thing to he got all the equipment and
blah blah blah blah and I was like okay
cool
hook us up so he hooked us up and matter
of fact the day that bland on the chico
met bland on we were coming from dick
griffeys office doing a record deal when
you met with blend all right so what we
did we was coming from dick griffeys
office but I don't call me I thought oh
man let's just go by and get a coke
burrito so in his restaurant you know
you know we ain't gotta buy no food
today you know so we really stopped by
to do that and then he started talking
about cocaine and uh Chico was like man
let me know what let me know what you
know how much after that did he do it I
know it's a three hundred thousand
dollar deal or three fifty someone know
we supposed to be a million dollar deal
I suppose been a main
the 300,000 was listed down payment on a
million dollar deal 10,000 per yeah 100
kilos million dollar deal 10,000 per so
so is it that day is that the day when
the deal was made and everybody showed
up or no no no no it took a couple weeks
after that you know he kept probably
about 2 or 3 months and we'll you
paranoid or why's this guy keep
following up or no I didn't really you
you know what what what I credit myself
it's almost like a drug addict who's
trying to kick the habit and you know
you keep dangling come on man just try
one time and I look at it that that's
what eventually happened to me because
my whole intention was to never sell
drugs again to never be involved with a
drug deal again those promise your kid
you said I'm not going to touch it I
promised my kids and I promised myself
to you know just like I did when I said
I was never going to use again but what
I notice now is that I had never totally
ruled out never selling drugs you know
like I still had I still had some things
you know like oh my kid get hit by a car
and they need a surgery for 50000 I'm
gonna get that 50,000 I don't care how I
got to get it you know I almost looked
at the theater as if it was almost that
important to me it's like one of those
kids that was kind of like my last
stronghold that I had from the game you
know that I felt would have given me a
boost in life that that I wanted walk me
through the day the event the day where
the FBI and everybody comes like what
was they like but they like well it
started off with us getting on the 405
freeway going to San Diego and danilo
didn't want to do the deal in LA I would
have beat this case if I would have
stayed in LA my lawyer told me that if I
were to stay in LA
then here to one in this case for me I
would got kinda gotta quit if you were
wise that why Nellie well I would have
had some black jurors got it
he said that blacks would have never
convicted me on this crime that they did
they at me they had they had me they had
tape recordings where he's dangling the
price Oh a 17,000 a kilo oh it's 14,000
a kilo
oh it's 12,000 a kilo oh it's 11,000 a
kilo so those are all inducements to
induce you into which is illegal they're
not supposed to the law is supposed to
be to catch criminals it's not for to
entrap a law-abiding citizen but the
people who wrote the laws were smart
enough to know that innocent people can
be duped and to doing a crime you nected
right save benson' if you know
somebody's been walking for two or three
days and they walk down the street in
this guy's like a man has some keys in
that car and you never even thought
about the car but now he just put that
on your mind
that's inducement that's induced yeah
and it's entrapment
so 17 14 12 11 10 yep and uh at 10 I
broke you know what would each I made on
that deal and a million dollars there
hundred kilos how much would you have
made I think they were gonna give me
50,000 I mean 150,000 H for setting your
deal up for hooking them up well they
were gonna pay you I got it so you're
not part of it kind of like you paid the
other guys 60 K yeah there were the page
150 kg or correct I got it so cheek was
gonna do the deal he's doing a movie not
here you're not involved well
technically I wasn't but I mean going by
federal law was I ate in a bed it with
aiding and abetting if if I know you're
doing a dope deal and I hand you the
keys to my car then you go to do that
dope deal then technically I just ate in
a beta too
got it got it so now what happens
blending comes well we get to San Diego
does he seem nervous as he hmm I
couldn't tell you no because I hadn't
done a dope deal I've been out of the
game for seven years now you know I
haven't done a dope deal in seven years
so I'm totally out of my element and
it's crazy you know people might not
understand what that means but it's like
when you haven't done something for a
while you are not practicing the way
that you always practice I mean your
timing is off you know it's just not
it's not you you're not the same person
you used to be so we get there it was
nighttime we was found doing the deal as
soon as we got there oh no I can't get
to the to the warehouse right now we got
to do it first thing in the morning so
we wind up having to get a house I'm
gonna get an apartment and it's been a
night there I was still on parole too
wasn't posted being in San Diego that
was a violation for me to even be in San
Diego so we woke up the next morning
when we met with him at a Denny's he
asked for the money I told him we want
to see the drugs he had this white guy
with him who's who's a DEA agent posing
you know as another one that connects
Chico handle the money they told us what
a car was didn't it Oh hand me the keys
to the car I threw the keys - Mike Mike
jumped in the car
I opened up the back of the car and
looked at the boxes where the kilos were
supposed to be I saw some packages that
look like kilos they were wrapped in
tape and everything like normal you know
I told Chico okay everything good I
jumped back in my car you know I
commenced to taking off when I pulled
out this car tried to cut me off
and I swerved and went around it not
really paying any attention but then
when I got up a little ways further to
black and white police cars blocked the
intersection so I had to swerve turn for
missing him
and I knew it was a setup from Nia I
look back in my rearview mirror I saw
him Hachiko and uh and Curtis out the
car
spread it out you know handcuffing them
you know I saw him have Mike and then I
saw Danilo standing on the side with the
DEA you know laughing and you know like
a job well done what are you thinking at
the time were you driving unbelievable
you know
I'm looking at a life sentence without
the possibility of parole
you know I knew the law because I'd saw
other guys get the same thing at that
time I had a conviction from Cincinnati
and Texas so it looked like in my mind I
was a tree striker I thought I was a
tree striker
so that was gonna be my last day on the
street probably more than likely and and
and then two Sims I'm still young in my
mind you know I don't really you know I
don't really understand about a lot of
stuff you know I was smarter than I was
when I went to prison but I was nowhere
near at the level that that I was gonna
be home so then you go in you get out
you get life you start reading studying
law and this is when you realize the
whole three-strike and your negotiate
and you did you represent yourself to
get out of it or did you have somebody
else I hadn't I don't know you get a
little annoyed what point did you know
he says I think I can get out of this uh
it was probably at about three years so
being in and we were getting ready to to
get sentenced and I told my lawyer I was
like look man you know well I felt first
we felt that that we were going to get
the hope we should have got my location
have been reversed because you know
Danilo Brando had an illegal green court
that the jury never knew about
I felt that had the jury known that his
green card was bogus that one of the
agents forged his green card could have
made a big difference in front of the
jury but you know an appeals court and
everybody said it wouldn't
a difference you know but technically he
should have never been allowed to
testify he should never been allowed to
testify
no no because he should have been
allowed to do the setup in all states
that if youõre a lien that's convicted
of a drug crime you must be deported not
that you can be deported
you must be deported can the government
to immunity give them the freedom to say
it's okay we're not going to they can
they can the Attorney General or the
President of the United States goes to
only once interesting happens all the
time though with these immunity deals
very interesting deals they break the
laws their own laws right but the only
person that can allow him legally are
those two people who not a i ns agent
not the chief of iron ass
I was the president late nineties Bill
Clinton was he didn't do it
Genet Attorney General did it she didn't
do it either then who did
a DEA agent i NS agent forged his green
card how do you know that well we got a
tip my lawyer was in his hotel room so
an irony agent calls him and says uh mr.
Fenster I got some information for you I
don't like what they did to Rick I think
what they did to him was wrong and I got
some information for you so my lawyer
said what you got he said well I don't
really know what they did to get this
green card but it was illegal he said
it's almost impossible to get a green
card for a convicted felon especially
somebody who was sold as many drugs as
he is so I think he'd think they
convicted him for over 10,000 kilos of
cocaine so when my lawyer you get this
call the next day we go to the court
we're going to trial
this is doing trial and we're is this
ninety six now we should have had this
information in Brady versus Merlin Brady
versus Merlin is saying that the
government's supposed to turn over any
information is favorable to my defense
you know if it makes a cop look bad make
the informant look bad they supposed to
turn it over to us but they haven't
turned anything over to us they hadn't
told us how he got his green car
so we go to court so my lawyer we
sitting in court and my lawyers telling
me about him and I get this strange call
last night from this kind weird call you
know my lawyer he's you know he's
straight by-the-book on those Booker's
and he was like this guy tells me that
uh Danilo shouldn't have a green card
I said yeah she said yeah he said you
want me to question him about it I said
yeah Aksum about it let's see what
happened I said you know I'm looking for
anything I'm drafting four straws I'm in
the middle of the ocean boat went down
so he starts to question uh Chuck Jones
the DEA agent about it how did this guy
get a green card oh I don't know how he
got his green card but I know it was
done right but never committing oh I
didn't do it a I&S agent tell us handled
all of the green card stuff and and my
lawyer he blew it because he lured in he
should have put telling us on the
witness stand how do you put tell us on
the witness stand tell us what a lie
tell us what it got on the witness stand
and told him and told the people that uh
oh yeah I did the green court right
everything was done to the letter of the
law and then what did he do it why
didn't put him under with my stand I
don't know he thought that uh he thought
that the jury saw the conflict and the
the non direct answers by the DEA agent
and that that would be enough for them
to to have some doubt but after we know
because we got a hearing about the whole
thing we came back and the chief of ANS
came in and tell us his supervisor came
in
oh no Telus told me that the guy's going
to tell us never told me that the guy
had a conviction because they said his
his supervisor signed off so had the
supervisor did his job and went through
all the paperwork he would have known
that the guy was a convicted felon he
never did get me a green card but by him
knowing tell us that been an agent for
all these years he said that he knew
that tell us knew that a convicted felon
couldn't get a green card got it but now
it's his word against Ellis's were so
then you get you know you end up getting
how much to have for that you get 20 you
get life on your knife and then you
somehow someway you get yourself out of
it the three strikes I'll beat that to
me strike law you beat the three strikes
law you're out how much time did you end
up doing on the second time around 14
years in like seven months 18 months 8
months something like that 14 years
seven eight months yeah
now at this point of your life how
certain are you the CIA was involved in
the whole thing in the eighties well I
mean when the first one you know when
the story first came out I didn't really
I didn't really get Gary story much
credibility you know I was like ah it
was only after I started to dig and do
the research and Danilo screen card and
just you know all the stuff surrounding
it you know like how did this guy get
caught with ten thousand keys and do 28
months in prison you know and they got
guys that got caught with to two ounces
that's doing life without responsibility
parole how did this all work you know
and I guess the really convincing point
for me was when the CIA did there they
report and they said that you know we
knew these guys were selling drugs you
know we filed a report action attorney
general that we not have to
report them to law enforcement that I
knew that Gary was onto something didn't
director of CIA show up to Crenshaw or
LA or something like that
he came Chico Calder well he called he
came to lock high school yeah at a town
hall meeting what he he said that he was
going to be getting to the bottom of it
and that the people believed him
no well you know that's when Chico
confronted him you know Chico told him
something like well you saying that you
guys don't know if he was involved but
you sent a letter to our judge telling
our judge that you knew absolutely that
he wasn't involved we're gonna be
getting sentenced Monday on the premises
that he wasn't involved in now you
telling people that you don't know if he
was involved or not which was it you
know it was like a double standard no
Chico he said I'm facing seven and a
half and you're facing life right yeah I
was I was just impressed that he showed
up I just don't know if the people
trusted him if your signature name is
then entrust you to trust him now yeah I
think that was I mean they gave it to
him that hey I bet then I'd never do
that again yeah so so when you got the
news with Gary well how did you react
when the whole suicide oh he shot
himself in the head twice you know I've
never heard of anybody shooting
themselves in the head twice what did
you say and well you know I was doing a
documentary with with Kevin Boothe I
don't know if you ever heard he carries
from Texas to matter of fact Kevin is
the guy that introduced me the Alex
Jones Kevin was doing a documentary
called the great white hope and he
wanted me to be in a documentary so we
have been talking for a while about a
month on that documentary and in jail
you know you only get 15 minutes on the
phone so my 15 minutes was up that hour
and so I was waiting on the next 15
minutes comin when that 15 minutes came
I called Kevin so we could resume our
conversation and that's when he told me
that uh what happened to Gary I was
totally blown away couldn't believe it
it was just like strange for me like you
know how could somebody who such a
champion for justice
you know how could he be gone like that
you know and he was in the middle of his
lifework I guess what I would call him
did anybody investigate it or no did
anybody pursuit to see you know who it
was anything like that or not really I
don't I don't really know I think people
were fast to to have it done with you
know to be over it and to be gone to to
the next to the next thing and I know
the government was definitely glad that
uh the Gary wasn't around I mean Gary
Gary was he I mean not just what he did
with that case I mean Gary did so many
great articles and and things for
personal he did but even Michael Levine
told them he says listen I don't think
it's a good idea when they went on
Montel Williams and the whole thing took
place oh yeah Libyan told him says I
don't think you're doing the right thing
right now because it's too much exposure
yeah and eventually you know guy ends up
shooting himself twice you know at this
point the one question I do want to ask
you is the following and this be the
last topic I want to kind of talk before
we get into your book and some of the
projects you're doing so I grew up in
Iran okay I lived there ten years you
know when I talk to other people in Iran
who experience war being bombed on the
fears the anxiety that always stays the
whistling sound when you watch the
movies you have flashbacks because I
come from that world two years I live in
Germany at a refugee camp my parents
split up my parents get a divorce I
don't see my dad for a year and a half
then I come to Glendale California and I
see my dad once every other week for one
day so I saw him two days two days a
month for six years then I joined the
Army and it seemed for you two and a
half years and then I saw my friends
going back and forth and a lot of times
people ask me to so that I can meet him
become a drug dealer drug addict all
that all this other stuff my year one of
my best friends became the biggest drug
the
bringest seller of a path in Glendale I
go to the army I'd come back this guy's
like we get in a car one day literally
we're in the car one is black Mustang
we're driving the car me and him in a
fan of ours Devine if he's watching us
he would remember this this Z for BMW
shows up right next to us red light okay
we're on Los Feliz and the guy goes like
this light to light we race he meets him
the guy shows a badge my buddy gets
pissed he says pull over the car the cop
realizes who he is he runs off he chases
him down pulls him over in the middle 5
freeway you know 5 free where bye bye
the rabbi the Dodger Stadium if you know
the whole Griffith yeah right there
pulls him over right there gets attitude
I said what are you doing I'm on
vacation from Army I'm on leave he goes
and spits on the guy's face is like I'll
turn your kids into drug addicts if you
ever do that to me ever again the cop
takes us to 7-eleven bison every since
what can I get you gives them a car
whatever you need I'll take care of you
I mean I immediately remember this right
and I go back and I said what the hell
happened last nine months and someone to
the army what happened to you you were
3.5 GPA kid and I go back to see what
made him turn right man so for you my
communities middle eastern I grew up
with Latinos African Americans I joined
the Army in the Army I got along with
African Americans and Latinos because I
kind of feel like we're minorities right
right and they're now men insurance so
Caucasian so it's kind of conflicting
but I asked you you seen a lot you grew
up in LA you grew up in Crenshaw Steve
it's the pinnacle right what what do you
see being a solution for helping a lot
of this crime gangs drugs what what do
you see being a way to find a way to
minimize it economics tell me what you
mean by that well when when you have
people who who can't can't sustain obey
fit basic living
rent food shelter clothes maybe a car
when you don't have those elements to be
possible then you allow the mind to
wonder and try to figure out ways to
accomplish those goals
I don't think drug dealers or bad people
at all and I know a lot of people I said
that one time and somebody one went
crazy home I don't I don't think anybody
all right
I don't think I see them as you know you
have an operation on the preneur just
trying to make money yeah they saw an
opportunity I want to see the seat
because for me trying to process an
issue you know this is the drug dealing
was a final product right you know
that's the results of so I want to know
this seed I want to know the seed what
happened here this is what I want to
know and you're in that world so well he
wants to be he wants to be a member of
society he wants to be somebody of means
somebody that gets respect you know just
like everybody else
I mean everybody we all literally almost
think the same things in life some of us
take different avenues to get there and
and sometimes that those avenues become
circumstances that happen in your life
you know like with you I mean when it'll
shoot insurance what the first person
made a girl named Jean Pierre we're at
Venice Beach her and I started dating
she picked me picked me up in a
different car all the time I was trying
to be a bodybuilder I just got on the
army it was broke I was making for 75 an
hour 525 an hour and you know I said
what do you do she's I work in Morgan
Stanley Dean Witter I said I want to be
able to work there you do to the Greek
and so then eventually I got a job at
Morgan Stanley Dean Witter six months
later day before 9/11 and that's how I
got it - I got my series 766 3126 life
at home in a life went that direction in
that same way with me that's the way I
started Simon cocaine it's the way I
started selling weed when we when I got
off parole you know
I was getting eviction notices at my
house because I wasn't selling enough
books and t-shirts to sustain you know
that I've started out that I was living
and one of my friends came over and he
was like man they having this big
convention at San Bernadino Fairgrounds
and it's a wee convention you ought to
come and you all parole now loosen up
man and and what would I notice at that
time is that I hadn't even saw the weed
industry
I never calculated on myself being in
the weed industry when I was in prison
it was the furthest thing from my mind
do you think you're going backwards if
you go back go back into cannabis today
you don't think you're going back to the
same thing no I don't think so
I look at cannabis as cannabis is a
benefit for us it has medical benefits
it puts people in a space of a piece you
know I mean if you ever get a chance you
got to go to one of those one of those
kind of events and I mean everybody
there is just so peaceful and happy you
know and and and loving I'm not
questioning cannabis I'm not I had a
marijuana debate a month ago I brought
the commander of US Navy intelligence
and I brought the developmental director
from normal as that is normal and I had
them debate right here it was an hour
and half debate intense debate back and
forth so you understand man 1 I
understand marijuana but I'm not talking
about marijuana I'm talking about you
and marijuana and I'm no different than
nobody else no but I'm talking about you
you know the next level and how much
more the profits can be don't you think
for you it's more playing with fire than
the average guy oh no you don't think so
mm-hmm I would never go back to selling
cocaine no matter what happened what do
you say that because the only song
cocaine because I had no other Avenue of
making money of making money
I was stuck don't you think you could
have been a sales manager and put a team
together and go out selling like I
didn't know that at the time can you can
you can you imagine if you have somebody
who who think that they're dumb stupid
they think they're gangbanger you think
they're thief do you thought that what
you thought all those things about
yourself absolutely but you're in credit
yeah but I didn't understand that I
didn't understand that you could be
incredible in math and I didn't know I
was incredible with people that I I mean
I had at that time I probably had about
15 20 guys then followed me everywhere I
went
if I said to do something they would go
and do it you say it's what if you grew
up in Beverly Hills 90210 15 miles away
from Crenshaw okay 18 miles away
whatever the number is 18 miles away I'm
three different family I would have been
a different person you would have been a
different absolutely so then when you
going back to economics so going back to
some of these communities that Crenshaw
you pick Southside Chicago pick some
parts in New York pick some parts of
Miami pick some parts of even Dallas
here you know there's some bad areas
advisor as well I'll come here and speak
to I spoke in Dallas
there's there's a brilliant guys in
Dallas Oh cliff yeah Oh cliff that
that's right so what what can what can
the community and the government do to
inject hope in those areas anything well
we we gotta we gotta offer opportunities
you know people people when they don't
have opportunities they get hopeless and
you know a hopeless person they don't
care if they live or die you know when
you got somebody who who don't know if
they're gonna have a place to sleep they
don't know if they're gonna have food
you know they don't have a girlfriend
they don't have family members that care
about them then they get hopeless you
know and I think so much centers around
I mean just look at like the guy who
just did to shoot another day he just
lost his job
they don't think that that had any
effect on him committing the crime that
he committed absolutely because when you
when you feel hopeless then you don't
care about yourself so you can't care
about anybody else and and I think that
that's the same thing that our kids are
going through right now in in these
areas and that's why I do my job right
now let me ask you this take take the
bottom 20 worst communities in us okay
okay take bottom 20 I want to hear what
you're gonna say about this bottom 20
it's a required reading to read those
three books before fifth grade
absolutely let's just say we do that
and let's do the math for those kids
bottom it's a hundred thousand kids
let's just say it's a small 100,000 kids
if they were required to read richest
man in Babylon thinking Grow Rich as a
man think it right right before sixth
grade if they were required to read that
you think how big of a difference you
think it would have made percentage-wise
tremendous to men what is tremendous at
a hundred thousand percentage-wise
probably ninety percent you think that
big of a number I think so that's a big
number you're talking about so so me and
Scott come our politicians aren't
recommending kids to read books
welcome how come we're not recommending
some of these books for us to read well
I don't really know the community they
never go in the community we have people
making decisions for us that has never
been in a community like we have people
who make laws that have never been to a
jail like how can you tell how much time
a person should spend in prison when you
never been to the prison you don't know
what it's like to go to prison they
never come to our communities they never
get out to to to to need to go to jail
to be able to know how to influence I
mean it's kind of like saying I'm a
gynecologist but I'm a man I've never
had a kid the reason why I don't want to
use that is because they'll use that as
an excuse what I'm saying is why aren't
they creating opportunity myself okay
I'm a math kid at a 1.8 GPA in high
school okay if I was a new community I'm
probably running with you grind but I
might save you what's army because the
guy named haste was gear on came and
told me says you were headed towards bad
side pride part of any sign me up for
the army I went to the army life changed
right I was working at Burger King I'm
like a regular guy doing nothing right
but the reason why I asked that is I'm
trying to see one I rarely ever hear any
campaign any politician talk about let's
have our kids read the right books they
don't they don't I totally agree I mean
even even my book I've had teachers read
my book and they asked me why am I so
blunt in my book and I said because our
kids are tired of BS
we've been BS in the mall in life don't
do this you can't do that this is good
for you that's bad for
and then when they come up like I told
you before most people who start to use
drugs I did a survey I was in I just
left Kansas City last week and I spoke
at a couple schools the turn of schools
and I asked all the kids in the schools
who introduced you to drugs the first
time guess how many said a stranger
how many none come on
not one everybody said oh my brother my
father my auntie my sister my cousin now
one person said that some strange guy
came up and introduced me to the drugs
it's not going to happen it's usually
somebody who love somebody you trust
what's your point do the point is is
that our influences is the reason that
we do most of the things that we do so
do we go to the influencers to help them
or do we go to the kids well we go to
both weird we attack both how do you
help the influencers how do you help the
kids well most of the influencers got
involved with drugs because they wanted
to what get some money yeah they wanted
to make some money
sure they got hooked on the drugs
because they experimenting with it so if
we can help them become financially
stable where they now feel good about
themselves where they feel that their
life matters because most of them don't
feel like they life matters nobody cares
about my life my life is worthless then
they can start to also influence the
people that they normally introduce the
drugs but what are your thoughts about
the fatherless kids I mean you know the
stats you hear about from the Census
Bureau definitely have an effect I was a
fatherless kid in prison 65 percent of
guys don't have fathers in prison in
prison 65 percent and it's about the
same number for the ones who can't read
so there's a dire direct parallel to not
having knowledge in going to prison
I did a radio show I was in st. Louis
about about four or five years ago and I
was
on a radio show and the guy that was
doing the show with me he did a survey
on the people who got killed in st.
Louis you know st. Louis at that time
was I think leading the country in
murder rates and and he wanted to know
why so he did a survey he said all the
guys that got all the people that had
got killed that year not had a high
school diploma so what that told me was
not being smart was a direct connection
to you being killed so you having a
father figure growing up with you you
would have been you would have possibly
been a whole different human being oh
absolutely absolutely anybody I mean
because my whole my whole thing is that
I was looking for I was looking for
knowledge
I wouldn't took cocaine if I wasn't
looking you know I would have missed it
but I was looking for an opportunity to
to build myself on yeah you know i Don
Lemon once said from CNN more than 72
percent of african-american birds are
out of wedlock was what he said Wow 72
percents a big number right there how
much you think values and principles
plays a role Oh Toto man values and
principles or the keys you know if you
got values and principles then you can
do anything but without those values and
principles then you'll do anything the
other way you know Chris Rock is it
Chris Chris Rock the comedian one time
he's telling this joke he says you know
the one thing about men and women you
know the media is trying to make women
say you don't need man you can be
independent all this other stuff he says
go try raising a kid and you go tell
your boys what to do then let the father
say something joke about it yeah well
you know women are little cuz I got two
babies now then I'm raising in a women
or lighter on their kids than men on you
know a man is more firmer more stiffer
and and you know he's probably gonna be
the breadwinner
you know usually the male is the
breadwinner so when you don't have that
person to teach you how to bring in the
bread and then you become lost and not
knowing how to bring in the bread and we
you went into the male figure the other
thing too you know like when you're
growing up in the ghetto the first the
first entrepreneur that the most black
kids the Spanish kids are gonna meet in
the ghetto entrepreneur is the drug
dealer you know and then the next one
might be a robber car thief a pimp
you know these are the role models when
I was sitting in prison one day and I
was just playing with my mind and I was
saying what if they would have had a IQ
tests on criminality you know how well
would I have scored because all the
crimes that I hadn't committed I knew
how to commit them because guys in the
neighborhood had told me how to do it
so when you look at the career choices
that that our people are having you know
a lot of times they feel like kids BS
and then you top that it's a good point
it's not like you're not willing to
learn it's just what's being fed to you
to process in your mind
exactly and then we're letting Street
dudes outwork the people that supposed
to be teaching you know most teachers
don't want to be there
you know they want to be somewhere else
you know I really want III spoke at a
school in LA and and I did a survey I
spoke to all teachers it was all
teachers conference I said I said I
spoke to the kids and then I told I told
the principal say man I want to talk to
your teachers too because your teachers
have to have that concern for the kids
that our artists has for his art
and a lot of times these teachers don't
have it and when I did the survey with
the teachers I was accident I was like
what was your first choice of a career
did you did you did you want to be a
teacher and most of them didn't want to
be teachers they're just doing teacher
teaching until they get to the point to
where they can go to the next field
and if you have these type of people to
people if you got somebody that want to
be a rapper or singer and they teaching
your kids or your kids getting that
undivided it's like when I go teach I
teach tennis in two three yeah right now
today I talk tennis this summer to kids
for free just because I love it you know
you're glowing right now just talking
about it my partner who was on my tennis
team with me is his camp but he said
that he saw the kids give me something
that they don't give him and he
recognized it was behind my passion and
I put in it you know like I put my
tennis shoes on I go out and hit balls
with him yeah he do a little bit but not
not to the point like when I hit balls
with him I'm hustling like they should
be hustling and people have a tendency
they recognize that our kids recognize
that like I really care about you you
know I really love you and and if they
don't feel the same way you know they go
to class and they go home and they tell
I don't like my teacher don't like me
you know once they say that Dan that
teacher you know it's crazy you're
saying this let me tell you I got three
kids okay my oldest since the day he was
born he was serious he's three months
old
this is his pictures what is wrong with
your kid he'd look at everybody I let
you say he just met you this is what he
would do to you he just looked at you I
think that's not appropriate you can't
look at people like that so he's getting
older nothing's changed
till today serious so he goes to
kindergarten to this teacher yes I'm not
gonna say the name but so every day the
teacher says your son is not this your
son is not good at this your son is not
good at this
Suns not gonna diss all this stuff by
the end of the year she recommends out
of the 8 kids for 7 to be held back one
year your son is now ready to go to
first grade and I said I'm sorry yeah
your son's not ready to go to first
grade so when they I sit down with her
let me ask you a question you have eight
students seven of them you're allowing
to stay back one of them you're
advancing is your grandkid right because
you know I'm talking he says yes I do
I said do you know how to lead creative
kids or do you just know how to lead
people who follow your orders is this
private school that were paying three
four five thousand dollars a month able
to lead private creative kids right she
didn't have an answer so I go to the
principal I tell the principal I said
that's the worst teacher I have ever
seen in my life
a teacher like this can hurt a kid
because a kid camping has problems one
day my son comes here right here I have
the picture we should put this picture
up by the way he comes right here my
wife says he's got to see you so I don't
know what's going on with that he thinks
he has problems because the teacher
teacher told him you're different so he
comes to me sits here it says daddy
everybody tells me I'm different
everybody tells me I'm different I said
of course you're different
your daddy's different buddy we're
different we're the same but you don't
want to be like everybody no that's what
we're special he cries and my wife is
sitting there crying emotions she took a
picture and she got it and we're both
crying together in that moment then next
year my son we keep him gonna clip into
school makes he has this other teacher
during that year for that teachers class
one of the classmate girls gets cancer
dies at six years old kid dies at six
years old the other kid gets cancer she
goes on chemo for 3-4 months this
teacher gets Teacher of the Year award
she changed my kid's life she understood
how to deal with a create a kid one
teacher almost screwed his thinking at
that age ten Kenny has problems the
other kid says no you got gifts the
other teacher I think one had hated
teaching right the other one loved
teaching goes back to what you're
talking with tennis absolutely so you
know it's interesting you're saying what
the points are making with the challenge
being teachers you know to wrap it up
you
no I don't know if you remember Calvin
Oh buts
Calvin Otis Oh bots remember Reverend
Calvin tobots together came out and said
we're not against rap we're not against
rappers but we are against those thugs
do you remember that whole handling them
and then you know
bone thugs-n-harmony put it in the sound
it's the thuggish ruggish bone at the
beginning so that was the beginning of
the pastor so based on what you're
saying my biggest thing is prior to
somebody becoming a thug manure egular
kid that have the ability to do so much
big and based on some of the ideas you
got I can only imagine what things would
happen if people applied some of these
ideas last thing to do with you speed
round I'm gonna give you a name you tell
me the first thing that comes from I'm
not guy I tell your name you tell me the
first thing that comes to your mind okay
Arthur Ashe great officer robert wadis
corrupt 2pi the genius ronald reagan
thug Gary Webb a manatorian humanitarian
yes Bill Clinton I don't know jury's out
on deal a patriot rapper Rick Ross fried
Obama politician 25 year old Rick Ross
lost
Danilo Blandon lost Pablo Escobar Pablo
Escobar rich powerful rich rich and
powerful rich and powerful Maxine Waters
courageous courageous Daniel Ortega mmm
and you want a girl I guess he was a
patriot who's a patriot Manuel Ortega
and it's interesting to say talking to
you because you know you have
experiences that people don't have and
you can give perspective from a
standpoint where everybody can get
smarter to know how we can make a
difference on a lot of kids lives so
they can take a complete different
direction in their life so I appreciate
you opening up your book window put
links below to your book okay as well as
you got some real cool shirts you sell
out I love what Rogan did man a lot of
respect for Japan shout out to Joe Rogan
selling the shirts he wears it you know
the real Rick Ross is not a rap or do
you still sell that shirt or no steal
it's the other day
yeah classic let's put a picture up you
know the real Rick Ross doesn't so you
know they counterfeit that shirt who did
people on internet relevant confident
yes we're gonna some likes I'm like Nike
yes a compliment you know I put yours
below for people to be able to buy you
counterfeit it you know you can so
freeway Rick Ross appreciate you flying
out you thank you willing to open up and
be a guest somebody Taemin thank you for
allowing me this opportunity and
speaking to you was from a totally
different perspective you know so often
people you come in and you talk to
people and they just go over the same
things over know you so drugs and it's
like this thing is more complicated than
that you know a lot of people they want
to blame me for the drug problem but
then I say well maybe you might have to
blame Mike the guy that put it on the
table for me the first time and then you
could even go even deeper than that and
say well maybe we're gonna blame the
guys that made Superfly because that's
what seed at first it's a whole
different conversation man because
movies has such a big impact on
I rap rap rap so much to be talked about
about that you know where our kids are
getting their influences from and then
you know it's so funny I know we get
ready to wrap up but you know I go to
school sometime and I want to speak to
our kids and they won't allow me they
don't want our kids to get that
experience you know what it was like and
how you got started and who's gonna
introduce you to drugs because now your
kid is running around saving your kids
running around and he thinking oh it's
gonna be some strange monster that's
gonna come up and introduce me to drugs
but Dennis's uncle or his brother Wow oh
is this cousin you know somebody that he
genuinely cares about or his best friend
at school you know somebody that's the
Macho Man you know whoever whoever it is
but it's not the way that they're being
taught so they're not prepared for that
conversation that's gonna come you know
you're not prepared for when your uncle
offers you drugs you know you're
prepared for when this monster comes up
this guy in the park when you never saw
before and he got a hood over here he
comes the end he's a little boy I got
something for you
he's probably gonna run because that's
how we teach our kids don't talk to
strangers
but now when Johnny his best friend at
school he walks to school with every day
who's uncle just turned him on he didn't
know no better no Johnny who don't see
the effects yet cuz it takes a while for
the effects to come he automatically he
turns your son on and that's what's
happening to our kids well I'm hoping
the right people watch this man I'm
hoping the right people because all
basic thing about the right books can
change people's lives it did it you did
it to me man oh absolutely
I read fifteen sixteen hundred books
completely changed my life time you see
the bookshelf over there I'm about I
don't have a four-year degree I don't
have a two-year degree somebody simply
my sister recommended me how to win
friends and influence people write that
one - Robbie Saldana recommended me how
to master the art of selling my Tom
Hopkins and for me I've got a dick
that's I cannot believe this
informations and books and the rest is
history that's what I say it - when I
started
we brother again thanks for coming at me
truly really enjoyed it all mine all
mine is it was wonderful
likewise tank